[Music]
all right let's go to emily in boise
what's up emily
hi how are you i'm so good how about you
i'm doing pretty good excellent what's
up
all right so i guess a little back story
um i found out i was pregnant last year
at the end of july
and it was almost like the day i found i
was pregnant a light switch went off in
my brain and i became
like so scared of everything um
i think coming out of the pandemic
they're like don't trust any don't touch
anything don't do anything you're gonna
get sick and then pregnancy they're like
don't eat anything don't do anything
because not only will you get sick your
baby will get sick right
um so then
uh
i had really intense like ocd symptoms
kind of develop stronger and stronger
stronger throughout my pregnancy and
then i gave birth and everything was
okay for a little bit
and like i'm not as scared about like
bacterias and getting sick but i still
have like ocd
tendencies
so scared he's gonna get like lead
poisoning or anything like that so
anyway so i have like these compulsions
and behaviors that i do to like prevent
it
and i try to challenge them and remind
myself like
your logical brain know that
your baby likely won't get lead
poisoning
but if i don't wash my hands before i
feed him or if i don't do this or this
then
he will
so my question is how do i determine the
difference between like ocp thoughts
and anxiety versus like my actual like
mother's intuition
oh that's a good question
um can i ask you a few questions back
first
yeah okay
um
rarely and i mean super rare is
like you talked about the light switch
does it does that happen outside of any
sort of historical context
so
when was the first time you
experienced anxiety or intense anxiety
or some sort of repetitive ocd-ish
symptoms
and i'm talking about like as a kid as a
14 year old has this been your whole
life
it's my whole life okay yeah i have
memories of even as like a little little
kid
being scared okay
where did those come from
where did what come from
where did the idea that
i can i can make a path of safety for
myself moving through the world by
controlling everything i have to control
everything so that i can be okay
when did that story pop into your head
or who gave you that story
i don't know
i know so another little history thing
is i
uh had an eating disorder for a long
time and was in and out of treatment and
so i don't i don't struggle with that at
all anymore like it's almost like a
complete past self
but when i've talked about it with the
new ocd with like my family they're like
it's almost like you traded one for the
other
one form of control i would say the same
thing it's it's still the underlying
the underlying i don't use the word
pathology because i don't know you in
that context but the underlying
challenge is
i can can i can white knuckle i can grab
the steering wheel so tight that it can
never turn no matter matter the terrain
i'm driving over and we all know that's
not true or real so
most of us let go
some of us
grab one even tighter right and we end
up with elbow issues and shoulder issues
and then we go to the doctor and say hey
my shoulder hurts and they give us some
sort of
uh
injection some cortisone
or they give us shoulder surgery and
really the problem is we're hanging onto
that wheel too tight right so back and
all the way out at some point either
that was the way you stayed safe as a
kid
because you grew up in a house of chaos
um or you had people that were right
next to you but they were involved in
others they were busy doing other things
and so you were trying to figure out how
i can like what was wrong with you and
you took control of that relationship
that shouldn't have been yours to
control of or you're an abusive
situation as a kid we can unwind it for
a long way even something is simple so
my dad um one of the things he used to
tell me
was hey every decision every choice you
make in life
you're throwing a giant rock into a lake
and you never know where the were the
rings of that lake of that rock hitting
the water where they're gonna wash up on
on shore even if it's across the lake
and you're responsible for where those
rings wind up so be careful about every
rock you throw and that was great wisdom
and i did not know how to compute that
so i got paralyzed by every decision
because i would be like well i got to
play 70 different scenarios out here
right and i'd end up doing nothing and
so that's one of those even even my dad
with great intention
right he was giving me a gift also
it wasn't a benign gift right so
let's fast forward all the way till now
okay intuition
um is most often a set of
is our body remembering something
okay
so
either your body's remembering that you
were out of control once or was
remembering a time that you read or saw
something so i don't want you to
overthink intuition does that make sense
i don't want you to romanticize
intuition
yeah i think the fear is like
what like
hypothetically and i logically know he
likely won't get lead poisoning but he
does get lead poisoning and it's traced
back to something that i did and then
it's like i should have known better i
thought about it and i chose not to
because i was challenging an ocd thought
but actually that thought was
not ocd it was
real
i
um
there's not a difference
take diagnostics off the table they're
really confusing
they're mudding up your next step
okay you're i wouldn't think like is
this an anxious thought or is this an
ocd thought is this a real thought i
wouldn't think like that at all your
thoughts are your thoughts or your
thoughts
okay and so stop trying to pull them
apart and and splice them and dice them
just simply sit for a moment and say
if i don't wash my hands
is my kid going to get lead poisoning no
and your body will feel it and then you
can say hey thank you for taking care of
me
thank you for sounding all the alarms
i'm a good mom and i got this
and what you're doing is you are
letting go of the wheel instead of
tightening your grip on it
it doesn't letting go doesn't mean you
make bad choices or ding-dong choices or
you go rub your hands and like you know
cow manure and then go feed like that's
not what you're doing here but you're
also recognizing
um
we might get hit by a meteorite
and i'm not gonna spend my days
wondering what happens after a meteorite
i'll just deal with that when when it
happens you know what i'm saying
right definitely so the chance of you
know this statistically the chance of
your kid getting lead poisoning is very
very very low
unless he's eating paint off of an old
un you know
uh swing set somewhere we live in new
construction
right right so we know
that those alarms are not coming from
that fact
right the alarm is probably ringing off
the hook for one of two reasons
number one
you're a mom who just recognized for the
first time i
made peace with an eating disorder i
made peace with my body i've made peace
with my marriage i've made peace with
relationships
oh and then a huge variable just got
dropped into my world that i simply
can't control and i've heard it said i'm
watching my heart beat outside of my
body in this little boy
and i can't control any of the things
that happen moving forward
somebody's going to break his heart
somebody's going to be mean to him
he's going to get in a car and drive
across the country one day all by
himself he's going to get fired one day
those things are going to happen someone
he loves is going to get sick
those things are going to happen and i
can't control any of it
and one of two things we can move
forward is we can double down and say
i'm going to control it our body's going
to scream at us control control
or i can make peace with i'm going to do
the best i can with what i got
and i'm gonna make peace in that gap and
that's true healing does that make sense
so that's that's number one here's
another number two that could be the
case
it's not uncommon that somebody who had
childhood traumas when they have a kid
their body remembers that
and like so if let's say somebody was
sexually abused when they're seven it's
very common that somebody starts getting
really anxious at six when their kids
are six and a half super anxious right
and get really hyper vigilant and they
don't know that they feel like they're
going crazy and it's simply their body
remembering hey this isn't safe
and so it that could be the case too for
you
yeah i think it's more the first one
because i have i'm
uh my son's the 25th grandchild on my
parents side
and so
i was like i
i know what love is like i know what
love is like for because i have all
these nieces and nephews and
um
i had no idea
uh yes it was
so soul-altering all right so i'm gonna
give you the demon of anxiety you ready
and i don't mean that like in some weird
i don't know like horned pitchfork kind
of way but i mean this this is why
anxiety is the worst
the more you
give into it
the stronger it reinforces itself
because your brain says
hey if we need to wash our hands again
and that will make us feel a little bit
safer for half of a second right
so i wash my hands again and our body
goes got that little bit of
it feels good
and then the next time it's let's wash
them three times let's wash them four
times
and if you don't wash them four times
it's like
right so it just keeps moving itself the
only way through it is to turn and face
it and walk directly in the middle of it
right sometimes i do this thing where
i'm like i'm just going to pretend like
i don't have ocd anymore don't do that
don't do that like in the morning
don't do that walk right in the middle
of it know that know that i struggle
with anxiety
and by the way anxiety ocd i'm
i think they are exactly i think they're
on the same
i think they're two sides of the same
coin
right i actually have started thinking
i'm one i've always understood ocd to be
a derivative of anxiety i'm wondering if
it works the other way right now
here's the deal it doesn't matter it
it's literally academic gymnastics for
me at this point but i'm wondering if
um the the the neural loops that ocd
sits on is what spins out anxiety at the
end of the day who cares
when you start to need to wash your
hands uh for the third time or the
second time
stop
and intentionally look at your hands and
say they're clean
and i'm gonna lean into that discomfort
and then i'm gonna write it down did not
wash my hands again i feel uncomfortable
and i'm intentionally feeling this
discomfort
and i'm gonna go about it
i'm gonna go six minutes without washing
my hands again
right i'm gonna i'm gonna do these
things and lean into it here's the one
thing i'm i'm uh i want to caution you
against okay
your child will pick up on the titan
muscles
in the accelerated heartbeat and the
angst and now i'm making you angsty
about being angsty right i don't know
i'm gonna make it worse
um
no that those thoughts of
you're not planting anything
just watering them well right just
fertilizing the crap out of them um
i want you to aim towards
less towards getting every germ out of
your kid's life
and i want you to aim more towards
being as peaceful as possible
okay and that means i'm gonna head
directly into it the gold standard for
these type of things the nerd words is
exposure therapy
i'm gonna gently expose somebody to
something until their body stops
reacting to it
and we think we we think it's in our
head like i'm thinking like i need to
just want to quit having these thoughts
dude it's your body launching into
fight-or-flight as though someone was
giving your kid like arsenic or
something
right that's how your body responds well
like
logically i know there's not lead all
over my house but my body's on fire
that's right and here's the thing as
soon as you move from
lead you let lead go your body will move
to something else
right well that's how it was during
pregnancy i was scared of like
toxoplasmosis and all those terrible
things they say will
hurt your baby while they're in the womb
[Music]
he's born now and i'm like oh i can eat
whatever i want but
now there's other things that's exactly
right um i also by the way i'm not
opposed to a low-dose ssri it to help
rebalance the alarm system so that i can
do the work sometimes the alarms get so
loud it's tough
those type of things won't fix the alarm
but it will um
turn the volume down on it so that i can
go face i can walk into the walk into
the into the anxiety sometimes
okay that's something to talk about with
your doctor um don't go into your doctor
and say hey this dude on podcast said i
should be don't do that
you can say hey i'm really um these
these my alarm systems are loud and i
know they're not functioning right
because i know there's no fire in the
kitchen here but they keep going off
um
i want to look at some ways to rebalance
the alarms
my guess is
you've been struggling with this for a
long long long time
and what your body's in desperate need
of and quite frankly you deserve
is 18 months of focused i'm gonna clear
the anxiety from my body
i'm gonna live i'm gonna intentionally
build a non-anxious life
through relationships through
connection through exercise through
taking care of my thoughts to journaling
to going into the most anxious
situations
to having conversations do you have a
huge family
yeah okay yeah yeah you mentioned that
you have a thousand nieces and nephews
right how many brothers and sisters do
you have
uh five brothers and one sister
where are you in the hierarchy
uh i'm number seven and i'm
significantly younger than the six okay
so they were all born within 10 years of
each other and i was born seven years
after the youngest
okay
so
you can have very loving wonderful
engaged parents
but you had a very different childhood
than your brothers and sisters right
yeah i was raised with 40 year old
parents and they were raised with 20
year old parents
yeah
different people very different people
so you are gonna have to learn a new way
to operate in the world
and i want to i want to do a couple
things for you number one i want to tell
you this directly like i'm looking
straight into the camera right now
i
i've been i haven't been postpartum okay
but i have
the the feelings you're describing i've
felt them i've lived it and it's it's
been tough it's doubled me over okay
yeah and i also want you to know
that putting the work in is worth it
because on the back end i literally
don't have it at all anymore it's gone
it's literally gone
um
and it i feel like my body is completely
rebalanced itself
okay
so i'm telling you that because there's
a light at the end of the tunnel if you
want to do it but it is going to be an
overhaul i had to change the way i do my
life
um
do you have somebody that you can
tell what's going on in your head too
honestly
oh yeah you do
yeah i i do when i say it i talk i guess
what how do i describe it i say things
very matter effectively and so i've only
ever like actually broken down and cried
once to somebody why is why is there a
gap
i think because i don't want people to
like
actually think that i think that he's
going to get hurt or lead poisoning or
whatever that's not it that's not that i
want them to know
okay that's not it
somewhere along the way you were told
that what you feel and your needs are
not important other people's needs were
more important
yeah and you've been a peacekeeper is
that true
um in some ways i guess
at some point your body will figure out
a way to let
the fears and concerns
out and they will come out in weird
crazy ways if they're compressed
like lead poisoning
mine was i thought they were going to
nationalize housing
i thought that i thought the housing
market would implode again and then the
government's going to come in and
nationalize housing and i was gonna have
to pay like i and dude i had the math
charts that i drew i mean it was madness
and no amount of wisdom
could talk me out of it
and then i realized when i was reading
your book and you were talking about the
cracks i'm like that's how i feel yes
yes and yes and yes
usually when somebody's struggling with
ocd and anxiety like like you're
describing again it could be very much
hormonal but you've been dealing with
this for a long time it's often a highly
highly isolated person surrounded by
people who love them
yeah
i am a lighthouse surrounded by sons and
nobody can see me or hear me because
that's my job in this community in this
environment in this family system and so
i yell inside
and eventually that yelling comes out in
wacko ways
and then there's an industry that tells
me how to solve the wacko ways but never
gets to the core point
and if you are responsible for keeping
mom from from going off or for bothering
dad
or if you are always trying to well your
brother and your sister or sometimes the
youngest kid in your family system mom
and dad are tired
and it's like ah she's just a kid and
you kind of get left to your own devices
and it's cool and it's also whoa
probably not super cool or you make
different decisions or you find yourself
in different situations
are you marry somebody who is so great
but
my job is to make sure he's okay you see
what i'm saying
and it just settles in
and often that controls a kid is really
like a simple statement
do you see me and do you still love me
and i i can figure out ways that you can
see me
i'll be seen
right
right
your daughter's or your son's lucky to
have you
thank you i talk with a lot of folks who
don't give two craps about their kids
and your son's really really lucky to
have you as his mom
you don't believe that but i i don't lie
on the show
okay you think he got a second rate
broke down mom
who's anxious all the time and you're
not okay
yeah cool
yeah
um you've got my
which books do you have
um both both okay
um i'm gonna send you something else
that's gonna sound sideways i'm gonna
send you the questions for humans
couples editions both of them
okay i'm also gonna send you the friends
ones and here's why
i want you you still married
yeah
um good guy
yes
are you sure
[Laughter]
uh [ __ ] yeah okay yeah cool
um
i want you to have some intentional once
a week take these cards out and ask four
or five questions
my guess is you're
you've never fully connected with
somebody there's a disconnect between
your feelings and the words that come
out of your mouth
and that's anxiety
do you ever feel like if you start
crying you'll just never be able to stop
um
sometimes i guess
i cry a lot so it's
it's not something that i like really
prevent myself from doing but you don't
do it with other people
no yeah
well it depends certain people
okay
all right
are you meeting with a counselor
yes okay good
not is it not helping
uh i've i've been bouncing between
counselors
why
well i was seeing one that i really
loved and she did uh eft
and
she just she had a somewhat inconsistent
schedule like i couldn't see her once a
week
and
you just had to get on at the beginning
of the month and schedule all the
appointments that you needed and
sometimes there was only one available
yeah that's true that's not good yeah
that's not great yeah so then so then
you had to play the insurance dance of
who's in network and
anyway so i'm seeing somebody
um not great if they're hey if you've
been through it four times and it's not
good go to somebody else
it's it's talk therapy
okay and i just feel like i want
something more yeah
okay should you get the behavioral
things
i'll talk to him real quick one more
time i want you to lean into when you
feel the discomfort your first thought
should not be is this ocd or anxiety or
my mother's
intuition it your first thought should
be a smile on your face even when it's
annoying
my body's trying to take care of me
what's my body trying to protect me from
oh my body's trying to protect me from
killing my kid
awesome thank you for that not going to
do that today
i washed my hands and i'm going to feed
the baby and everything my skin is
crawling go wash them again go wash them
again go watch them again
ah thank you
writing down i'm gonna keep a little
journal next to me i'm gonna write down
wash my hands once before i fed my kid
my body wants me to do it again and i'm
gonna wait nine minutes
i'm gonna wait eight minutes i'm gonna
set a watch
and then we'll practice being
uncomfortable i'm going to lean directly
into this thing
and then after i feed my kid i'm going
to watch real close for signs of lead
poisoning which isn't even how that
works but
uh all right and then i'll exhale and if
i got to go wash my hands after nine
minutes 10 minutes after the alarm rings
cool i'll go do that
and i'm gonna move it to 11 minutes i'm
gonna move it to 15 minutes
and when i'm driving and i start to feel
myself grab the wheel i'm gonna let it
go and when i start to say something to
my husband that i need
and i stop myself from it because i
don't want to cause a problem i don't
want to i i don't want to be that guy
i'm
i want to be this kind of what
now i'm going to say it
i'm going to say it okay you see what
i'm doing we're practicing discomfort
we're leaning into this stuff okay
yeah
and my promise to you is if you will
take this walk and by the way get some
sleep and by the way
make sure you're taking care of yourself
with exercise make sure you're taking
care of yourself eating make sure you've
got a group of women that you do life
with you'll hang out once a week even if
you have to get a babysitter that you
can't afford to figure it out
um get with your husband have him keep
your kid get with a neighbor
whatever that looks like
the anxiety alarms will begin to
because your body will realize oh she's
driving she's in control of this thing
for the first time in our life awesome
that's great it's good
it's good
thank you so much for calling emily
you're not broken you're a good mom
and your little boy's lucky to have you
let's all for freedom which means let's
solve for
peace